[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est parti après les controverses
polémiques et appellent au boycott la
grande fête du football est
officiellement lancée et les Canadiens y
participent cette fois-ci
les violations des droits de la personne
au Qatar suscite de nombreux appels au
boycott de ce tournoi près de 6000
travailleurs étrangers seraient morts
sur les chantiers de la Coupe du Monde
au Qatar ces dernières années dans des
conditions s'apparentant à de
l'esclavagisme
certaines sélections dont celle des
Pays-Bas ont tenu à rencontrer des
travailleurs migrants le
Qatar réprime les droits des personnes
LGBT les partisans étrangers devraient
être tolérés par les organisateurs mais
les catharis pourraient être victimes
encore plus de répression après le
tournoi
le bilan environnemental du tournoi
organisé dans le désert fait aussi
polémique tout comme les conditions
d'hébergement et les restrictions sur la
consommation d'alcool
exaspéré la FIFA condamne les critiques
et accuse le monde occidental
d'hypocrisie sur la question des droits
de la personne
anyone
pour le Canada et c'est partisans se
tournoi est historique il s'agit de la
deuxième participation à la Coupe du
Monde la première fois depuis 1986 et
puis cette équipe elle va faire une
surprise on va affronter la Belgique la
Croatie mais thank y ne vous inquiétez
pas ça sera une surprise que le Canada
va créer dans ce Mondial ça a un
encourageante pour l'équipe canadienne
trois joueurs clés blessés dont la
vedette Alfonso Davies ont participé à
l'entraînement pour les partisans
Canadiens tous les espoirs sont permis
ici Philippe Leblanc Radio-Canada